thank you to Draper and it's hack the
moon initiative for supporting PBS
Digital Studios the red planet has
captured our attention throughout human
history with its relative proximity to
us and to the Sun early astronomers
thought it was possible for life to
exist on Mars we've imagined Martians as
everything from humans with silver
antennae to skeletal invaders with
exposed brains from a helmeted cartoon
to muscular forearms bipedal Warriors
and whatever this thing is
PBS even has its own Martians some
Martians are depicted as monsters while
others are allies why are they all so
different technology plays a role and so
does biology Natural History and war but
the whole Martian craze began with just
a single mistranslated word I'm dr.
Emily szarka and
his monstrum
the modern history of Mars began in 1877
when a crucial discovery was made a
network of lines was visible on the
surface the Italian astronomer who
discovered these grooves named them
Canali channels in English in 1895
astronomer Percival Lowell published the
first illustrated book on Mars
Lowell observed the same lines and
writing for an english-speaking audience
translated the word Canali to canals
rather than channels and that's what a
fateful mistranslation changed Mars
history forever he speculated how life
could survive there if it did indeed
exist but then Lowell's theories got a
little out there his book claimed that
the surface markings visible on Mars
were deliberate as no natural theory has
yet been advanced which will explain
these lines he theorized that what he
was seeing were changes in vegetation
made possible by a vast series of
irrigation canals and even though he
insists that he is only referring to the
possibility of an intelligent life form
on Mars
he also says certainly what we see hints
at the existence of beings who are in
advance of not behind us in the journey
of life now that a scientist has
suggested intelligent life on Mars the
public couldn't get the idea out of
their heads and the press had a field
day newspapers and magazines reprinted
Lowell's maps adding a visual element to
Mars mythology depictions and literature
of the time presented Martians as
humanoid in form and their society
utopian no war no poverty no social
classes no prisons and no alcoholism
Martians were portrayed as advanced
beings both in technology and
intelligence they were odd but kind of
appealing until the War of the Worlds
that is no not that one nope not that
one either further back
this one not only did HG Wells give us
one of the first alien invasion novels
of all time his Martians were very far
from human although they did possess a
superior intelligence they also wanted
to kill humans and inject themselves
with our blood
initially serialized in Pearson's
magazine in 1897 the story was collected
and published as one volume in 1898 and
was an immediate success it has never
been out of print it increased in
popularity after Orson Welles infamous
radio broadcast in 1938 on October 30th
listeners tuned in to hear his dramatic
reading of the book ladies and gentlemen
I have a grave announcement to make
incredible as it may seem both the
observations of science and the evidence
of our eyes lead to the inescapable
assumption that those strange beings who
landed in the jersey farmland tonight
are the vanguard of an invading army
from the planet Mars the show was so
realistic he managed to convince some
people Martians were actually invading
New Jersey other than my beloved yippee
ups and Marvin the Martian these were
the first aliens I was ever exposed to
and they left a lasting impression how
could they not after all htmls aliens
were essentially giant heads about four
feet in diameter with no nostrils of
fleshy beak large eyes and 16 tentacles
arranged in two bunches their internal
structure was basically all brain what
was so scary about these Martians was
their advanced war machinery Welles
describes a monstrous tripod a hundred
feet high capable of traveling with the
speed of an express train these machines
driven by the Martians
flexible metal tentacles heat ray guns
and a chemical weapon in the form of
black smoke see terrifying and what is
regarded is one of the best plot twists
in science fiction the Martians are
destroyed not by human military or
weapons but by bacteria while serious
persistent criticism of the supposed
canals on Mars began the 20th century
that did not stop authors from writing
about life on the Red Planet some
authors latched on to Mars as an
uncharted frontier ripe for nostalgic
romance driven by masculinists fantasy a
place for swords and magic beasts and
treasure slave girls princesses and
other beautiful female Martians just
dying to be loved by a human man even
film picked up on this trend following
World War one we see a shift in Martians
the human explorers traveling to Mars in
these texts were met with menace and we
see a surge of non-mammalian
extraterrestrials similar to earthly
insects reptiles or worms that were more
often than not predators stories of
aliens from this period could be read as
American anxieties about nationalism and
racial segregation when Martians were
described as more humanoid they were
still a threat because of their advanced
weaponry it wasn't really until after
World War two that Martians were more
commonly referred to as aliens the word
alien was specifically linked with a new
term and concept for the time the
unidentified flying object as consumer
cameras and recording devices became
more accessible so did the popularity of
UFOs people could now capture and share
alien experiences Martian literature
post-world war ii reflected a desire to
escape earth to flee from repressive
governments nuclear weapons and other
human created evils like in the Martian
Chronicles where humans flee earth for
various reasons including nuclear war
government censorship and racism
as its author Ray Bradbury once famously
said Mars is a mirror not a crystal as
our Science and Technology advanced and
the idea of life on Mars was largely
debunked a belief in Martians became
even more of a fantasy after the
invention of in space
telescopic photography and the Mariner 9
and Viking missions people pretty much
gave up hope that above-ground organisms
lived on Mars of course this hasn't
stopped people from creating stories
about them Mars is more visible and more
accessible to us than ever while many
still hold out for the possibility of
life on Mars buried deep below its crust
or in the polar icecaps we are more
concerned with trying to put humans on
Mars than encountering some kind of
life-form there today narratives about
Martians have changed we've moved away
from imagining Mars as a pre-existing
utopia populated by a Martian race
superior to our own now we envision Mars
as a utopia and waiting a promise of
hope and a better life off planet for
Earthlings PBS is bringing you the
universe with summer of space which
includes six incredible new science and
history shows streaming on PBS org and a
PBS video app like the planets from Nova
thank you to Draper and it's hacked the
moon initiative for supporting PBS
Digital Studios
you know the story of the astronauts who
landed on the moon
now you can log on to we hack the moon
comm to discover the story of the male
and female engineers who guided them
there and back safely hack the moon
chronicles the engineers and
technologies behind the Apollo mission
brought to you by Draper the site is
full of images videos and stories about
the people who hacked the moon
[Music]